joining us now for reaction is South
Carolina Republican congressman Ralph
Norman who joins us from Charlotte and
here in Washington is Richard Goodstein
he's smiling like the cat who ate the
canary
it's an attorney Democratic strategist
friend great to see both of you alright
congressman I got to start with you you
guys got the house you got the Senate
and you got the White House and now we
have a spindle Rama which I I imagine
Barack Obama must be watching this
somewhere comfortably and thinking man I
gotta hand it to you guys you guys
really you guys can do it better than I
can you could spend that money better I
can what's going on there congressman
well kind of Laura's unacceptable what
did you say dead fish that's that's what
I think this spending bill is the
Omnibus you know it's it's really an
insult to get a 2,200 page document and
get 16 hours to read it if you do the
math I have to read 137 pages an hour
and and digest it and and now we're on a
two-week vacation really the system is
broken we've gotten the 12
appropriations over back in September
and you know it's we've got to make a
change and I'm tired of it and I along
with a lot of other members I'm a member
of the freedom caucus we voted against
the rule today we simply were not
elected to bankrupt this country and as
congressman brat said you know we are
saddling our children with that if you
do the math every taxpayer it's a little
under two hundred thousand dollars I got
to play this I got to play a sound bite
for you guys
Nancy Pelosi who also seems very happy
she had an extra spring in her step
today said this let's watch it's
interesting to see from the standpoint
of regular order why the Republicans
thought that that would be a good idea
well I think one of the reasons they
rushed it through taking posting it last
night taking the rules on the floor
today
not honoring the three-day rule they
didn't want their voting colleagues to
see just exactly what was in the bill
well sue she's famously said you have to
pass it to see what's in it it's 2,000
plus pages we stacked it up last night
guys
and no one's reading this bill let's
face it you vote on it you get the heck
out of town the Senate looks like it's
gonna vote on it tonight because they
see what's the writing's on the wall
Richard good scene look I'm embarrassed
tonight as a Republican and that might
not sell on TV and maybe other networks
gonna do all six all the time maybe
they'll have higher ratings but I find
this to be really important we do not
have the money for this spending
Republicans campaigned on this and
Democrats look if I'm you I'm like
sitting back on what do we have to do
now yeah good stuff I feel your pain
seriously I know where you've been and
where Ron and others have been on
deficit spending at least when Barack
Obama was running up trillion-dollar
deficits we had the Great Recession to
recover from everybody is boasting now
about how great this economy is and to
run trillion-dollar deficits in the face
of that really is not right and you
talked with Sean earlier about sticking
to promises whether it's the border wall
or balancing the budget or bringing coal
jobs back yeah as you put it Donald
Trump knew how to win the election with
all due respect he knew how to win the
election by saying things that everybody
who knew policy knew he couldn't deliver
on no I didn't actually I don't agree
with y'all you can build a wall we can
we can put a man on the moon we can do
all the innovation we've done in
technology I think America could solve
pretty much any big problem ahead of it
if it wants to but in Washington Richard
it's both Republicans and Democrats I'm
not letting to believe I'm not on
Democrats off the hook because they're
big spenders too they they just want to
keep it all going because the lobbyists
get paid the lawyers get all the money
I'm a former lawyer believe me it's nice
to charge seven hundred bucks an hour
but the American people demand real
accountability reddit what bang are we
getting for this buck here is it really
gonna make all those Millennials safer
and more prosperous and happier
congressman you can chime in here but
look the Democrats didn't get everything
they want obviously Republicans there no
one's gonna get everything they want I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna come here
tonight saying the president was gonna
get everything but it seems to me he has
an opportunity or had an opportunity to
go to the American people and say I
campaigned on this I think this is
critical for the future of the country
if the government has to shut down
because both parties don't want to
protect our country that's real
sad but maybe we need to have a
conversation about that I think he had
to do that well and and you've got it
you can't let you can't let this process
continue with the threat of a shutdown
you know I was perfectly willing to have
a shutdown and set up in Washington DC
for six months or as long as it takes to
not have the giveaway programs that
we've had now the Democrats are a huge
part of this look what they if you look
at the vote today on the rule which all
the rule was is allowing the budget to
be voted on it barely passed 211 to 217
and 82 Democrats they don't have enough
Republicans congressman they needed the
Democrat votes of course the Democrats
are gonna support this why wouldn't they
why wouldn't they support us they're
gonna support it guys we got to get to
vote this is a huge news I'm sorry could
be I'll hold you both for an hour John
Bolton is replacing HR McMaster today
and my goodness MSNBC and others were in
a total meltdown World War three is
about to happen let's watch John Bolton
is known as a hardliner
clearly different than others in the
administration now on the Iran agreement
for example and it points to dangerous
signals so many millions of voters voted
against in 2016 who voted against stupid
Wars and bringing the biggest Hawk
there's ever been and put him as head of
national security
is awful for John Bolton he is the
hammer and everything is a nail I've
always loved that phrase but come on
rigid the idea that Bolton was gonna
like order Trump around okay you're
gonna go to war and country X I don't
think so drop Trump is not a military
interventionist even if John Bowles more
of a neocon your view but but he's
impressionable the the president is I
mean the explanation was well McMaster
was was more fond of the Iran deal and
therefore Trump had to get rid of a lot
well what my point is though we knew
where he was the Iran deal was a live
issue during the campaign to say now
well I hired this guy who didn't agree
with me why didn't you ask him when you
hired him and in fact is john bolton
seems to be more interventionist right
and at the same time that the president
stumping his track test about meeting
with Kim Jong on maybe doing away with
the North Korean nuclear threat if we
rip up that Iran deal within months
maybe you know we don't know how many
Iran's gonna be a nuclear threat in a
region that's a tinderbox yeah I think
congressman I think Bolton he does have
a lot of experience obviously at the UN
he knows the swamp been in Washington
for some time doesn't agree with the
president president does like to have
these differing views on his staff still
I think your reaction to this another
shake up tonight it's a great hire we've
we've had Bolton in meetings on Capitol
Hill he's knowledgeable he straight
forward he will not agree with this
president if he really doesn't think
it's in the best interest of the country
but one thing good about the president
Trump he encourages that now he is going
to be the one to make the final decision
but John Bolton I have the highest
respect for he is a heaven we have not
interviewed anybody in the meetings that
I've had where he hasn't answered every
question he sat for an hour and I after
two talking about foreign policy that's
his bailiwick that's what he likes and I
called the president for taking the
press MSNBC when have you ever heard
them compliment this president on
anything ever he could again cure lung
cancer and they'd be like why don't you
do it two weeks ago I mean no there's
nothing the president's gonna do they're
gonna love a great segment guys